he issued to produce reports identifying
challenges in our supply chains for a
set of critical products and for a set
of critical industries
when the first reports were released in
june he created a supply chain
disruptions task force at the cabinet
level to use every government lever to
address the near-term disruptions
related to the pandemic
one area he asked the task force to
focus on was ports and trucking
in july a secretary buda judge convened
all the key players from the goods
movement supply chain ports labor
trucking businesses and more
in august i joined the effort
to serve as an honest broker who could
help move everyone from finger-pointing
towards taking action
by october
the president brought together the
nation's largest retailers ports and
labor and earned commitments from all to
move toward a 24 7 supply chain system
we also worked with the ports to propose
fees on ocean carriers that were leaving
import containers at the ports in los
angeles and long beach for too long
this fee has helped lead to a 40
reduction in long dwelling containers at
those two ports
we work with the georgia ports authority
to provide flexibility to fund seven
billion seven million dollars of pop-up
inland ports to alleviate congestion at
the port of savannah
these pop-up ports started operating in
december
the port of savannah has also seen a
drop in long dwelling containers and
ships that anchor outside its port
and there have been several steps we've
taken in between to help get empty
containers removed to generate
commitments from leading retailers to
move their cargo during off-peak hours
and working with the state of california
to support infrastructure projects
there's still challenges
and omicron could surface more which
we're closely tracking
when bottlenecks emerge in the global
global supply chain it can take more
time for goods to reach store shelves
which can lead to price increases
that's why the president has taken such
aggressive action to alleviate these
blockages
and we've seen significant progress
first we were able to sustain a
record-breaking holiday shopping season
as you can see our preferred measure of
goods
on shelves inflation-adjusted retail
inventories without autos
five percent at the end of november
compared to the end of october to not
only exceed pre-pandemic levels
but also hit the highest
monthly level recorded since 1992.
consumers also receive 97 to 99 of their
packages on time or with minimal delays
from the us postal service fedex and ups
second as we begin the new year the
ports of los angeles and long beach
announced a new fee on long-dwelling
empty containers
building on the success of the fee
imposed on long-dwelling import
containers in november
this should help further unclog our
ports
third we're ramping up efforts to ensure
u.s exporters are treated fairly
the port of oakland for example
announced new actions to improve u.s
exports particularly agricultural
exports
fourth
we're monitoring potential omicron
related disruptions at ports overseas
and at home
while working to prioritize the movement
of medical supplies at the nation's
ports working closely with the biden
harris covid response team
the impact of the omicron variant may
continue to unfold and will remain
focused on report supporting the public
health response building on our progress
to help ease bottlenecks in critical
supply chains ensuring consumers have
the goods they need
i'll be happy to take some questions
can you lay out in detail what effect
you are saying that the immigrant
variant is having on the ports you know
and what are you seeing what are you
hearing from officials
uh in in the very short term uh there
have been some
increased outages from longshore workers
and others
so far that has not disrupted operations
uh as you saw earlier in the pandemic
there are procedures in place
in terms of personal protective
equipment and
safety measures
for the workers at the ports
and those
will be ratcheted up as needed
but as we stand here today
the the ports and the supply chains
are operating at record levels okay and
then i guess just my broader question in
the view of the supply chain task force
have these supply chain pressures peaked
it's hard to tell uh if the supply chain
pressures or p have peaked uh i think
what is clear is the pandemic laid bare
uh what was the underlying reality which
was the supply chain was stressed even
before the pandemic
and we clearly have uh changes to make
to build a more durable resilient supply
chain one of the great
things that's happened uh is with the
passage of the bipartisan infrastructure
law some of the physical infrastructure
upgrades
to infrastructure that was built by your
parents and grandparents
can actually be
updated through that infrastructure
program trevor um
one of the questions that's come up from
the trucking industry is about whether
back vaccine mandates are restricting
worker supply in that area is that
something that you've seen is that still
a concern
well first we know that uh vaccines work
and with 200 million americans
vaccinated
uh it's a big step forward throughout
the supply chain whether it's truckers
uh longshore workers uh distribution
centers or any other part of the supply
chain
we're working hard towards uh uh
vaccination uh which is the real
protection uh for americans um
going forward uh we've been working with
individual industries uh to make it as
easy as possible to get vaccinated
thank you so much thank you for being
here um the virginia department of
health said on tuesday that it's
experiencing supply chain issues with
getting profit 19
tests rapid tests can you speak to
what's being done to address that issue
not just in virginia but all across the
country and do you anticipate it being a
problem in terms of getting the half
billion tests that the president wants
to bring online
well first i think what that illustrates
is that the uh it's the global supply
chain and it's a global coveted uh issue
um that's affecting all countries we
have a procedure in place to prioritize
medical supplies as needed uh if you'll
see in today's white house blog that
there's a uh an example of within the
last week of medical supplies being
prioritized uh by the ocean carrier uh
by the uh um
longshoremen the railroads uh the
terminal operators to move those
supplies we're working closely with the
kova task force as they designate those
priorities uh we have a procedure in
place
starting with the
place of manufacture of those medical
supplies
to identify them early as they're put in
containers make sure those containers
are separately identified are what's
what we call block stowed stowed in a a
position on a ship where they can be the
first off
and then our prioritized for unloading
uh that would have to happen obviously
on a priority basis do you anticipate
that the distribution of the 500 billion
tests the president is looking to bring
online could be slowed down
we're working hard uh to make sure that
those tests are there when they're
needed and
together this
supply chain
with the millions of people that work on
it have met the challenges so far we
expect to continue to do that
hi thanks you mentioned the court of
oakland coming up with a short-term uh
measure to ease to alleviate some of the
pressure on the agriculture exporters is
there a long-term plan to help you some
of those same pressures on the ag
industry
yeah it's a great question uh
in many people focus on the import of
goods in the u.s which is important uh
goods of all kinds including
agricultural projects is every bit as as
important
the port of oakland
partnership that we have
is focused on both the short term and
long term in the short term
making sure that agricultural exports
that go out in containers
are not disadvantaged by the global
dislocations in supply chains
and in the long term
making sure that everything from the
ocean carrier service that brings those
american exports around the world
to the physical facilities at the port
of oakland and other ports
are in place
again it's a great example of where the
bipartisan infrastructure law can help
build the infrastructure that we need
today uh rather than relying on
yesterday's infrastructure
the last one we'll invite you back
thank you for taking my question um very
quickly the american trucking
association has said that there's about
80 000 um truckers that shortage of
truckers and so how is that feeding into
this disruption and what is the
administration doing to kind of com
compound those effects of the losses the
shortage of chuggers well first uh
secretaries walsh and buda judge uh have
been working hard uh to uh make sure
that uh uh that the trucking as a
profession uh is is more appealing and
uh it's not just recruiting new people
to trucking it's retaining the truckers
that you have
so um
whether it's
internship programs where you don't have
to pay for the training to become a
trucker which make it more appealing
or quality of life quality of job life
um
uh issues uh where
uh it's it's uh
people are more interested in staying in
the profession uh uh those are some of
the ways that it can be done
at the risk of stating the obvious the
private sector has an important part to
play here as well in terms of pay and
working conditions
thank you so much thanks for joining us
my pleasure thank you thank you
okay
i only have one item at the top for all
of you
um
just wanted to provide a brief update on
our federal testing sites which we
continue to expand and are doing strong
work to reach americans especially in
the areas where we're seeing uh the
greatest need throughout the holiday we
work to rapidly establish free testing
sites in multiple states and in the
coming weeks we'll have new sites
operating across the nation additional
sites are opening this week in
washington dc philadelphia with maine
maryland nevada delaware texas and
washington state to follow mobile
federal testing sites are now open in
new york city and new jersey which are
providing thousands of free tests daily
our 12 testing sites in new york city
alone have processed over 8 700 tests
since the first site launched shortly
before christmas these sites have been
effective in reaching a diverse set of
communities with 76 percent of those
tested in new york city and 82 percent
of those in new jersey self-identifying
as non-white these numbers reflect the
biden administration's commitment to
enduring or ensuring that our hardest
hit and hardest risk communities have
equitable access to testing uh with that
darlene
thank you
i wanted to start with chicago can you
tell us if the white house or the
education department or the
administration at large is
doing anything to help get teachers and
students back into school there
well
we are in across government we are in
regular contact with a range of
stakeholders on the issue of school
reopening and closures including
superintendents state leaders principals
teachers parents and other school staff
and that is certainly the case now today
this week as we're as the president is
working and we are all working to keep
schools open as the president said
yesterday uh he wants schools to be open
we know they can be open safely and
we're here to help make that happen and
he agrees with medical scientific and
education experts that because of the
historic work we've done we are more
than equipped to ensure schools are open
and we're going to keep our children uh
and educators who selfless who
selflessly serve their community safe
but ensure that children are not
enduring the mental health impact of not
being in school that we're there are not
gaps
in learning this includes schools
everywhere including in chicago
fortunately 96 percent of schools are
doing just that and just as a reminder
and i know i touched on this yesterday
but the president and our our
administration foresaw early on that
schools across the country would need
additional resources that's why he uh
fought for 130 billion dollars in the uh
american rescue plan for funding to
schools to implement mitigation
strategies including 10 billion dollars
in uh for for testing which has already
been distributed to states and the
department of education has also been
providing technical assistance and
resources for months now on everything
from implementing mitigation strategies
to connecting schools with testing
providers hosting vaccine clinics and
addressing pandemic mental related
mental health issues so long story short
we want schools to be open the president
wants them to be open and we're going to
continue to use every resource and work
to ensure that's the case so are there
any equipment needs or ppe or testing or
anything like that that you're hearing
from chicago that the white house can be
helpful with in terms of trying to get
schools off the virtual uh model and
back into the classroom well again 10
billion dollars in testing has been and
testing funding has been distributed to
states already uh prior to this month
last year that funding i i can certainly
check if there's more funding available
from the state of illinois but we're
encouraging states to
ensure that
that money is being spent is being
distributed to schools that need that
funding and we already distributed 130
billion dollars in uh in funding to
school two states to distribute two
school districts for mitigation measures
now different school districts have made
different decisions about what their
needs are over the course of the last
year but a number of school districts
did take steps to
put in place contracts with testing
contractors to ensure that they had that
availability and access for their
schools
go ahead thanks jen looking back to that
arp money does the white house wish that
there was more oversight in where that
american rescue plan
funding went since the president said
yesterday that some of the schools have
not used it well
and we're seeing in some places like
chicago and milwaukee
some of it's been earmarked for other
purposes including critical race theory
and in chicago you've got kids not going
back to school now well jackie it's
always been the case that local school
districts make decisions about what is
needed for their schools um that's
always been the case long before the
president took office um we did
distribute that money out to states as
he noted yesterday some have spent it
others have not spent it they've spent
it in different ways i would remind
everyone that when the cdc put out a
range of mitigation measures there were
a range of steps schools could take in
different schools some schools needed to
redo their ventilation some schools
decided to invest in more bus drivers or
more space so that they could socially
distance different schools made
different decisions what is important
for people to understand is that there
is some of this funding that hasn't been
spent in certain states to put in place
mitigation measures now is the time to
do that
and then on the new
cdc guidance it's
getting some criticism that it's
confusing
um that's the testing after leaving
isolation because it says that you know
you don't need to test after day five
but if you can get a test if you want to
test
and you test positive you should
continue to isolate until day 10. so
that would potentially create a gap of
people who are positive after day five
but don't test and go back out into the
community and then there have been other
policies that have shifted
including policy around healthcare
workers
needing to test negative before
returning to work and then that going
away
and also the note in the new cdc
guidance that negative tests don't
necessarily mean that you're infection
free
um so
is this is the cdc still
led by science and not by other
factors in determining its policy
well jackie the cdc is absolutely led by
data and science um and you know again
if they hadn't changed their
recommendations over the course of time
schools would probably be closed across
the country right uh they of course are
um continuing to address as they have
for the past year plus uh steps that
need to be taken in order to protect the
american people uh the cdc's guidance
did not add a recommendation for testing
including in workplaces uh the the cdc
director just answered this question on
a covet briefing about an hour ago where
she basically said there was a lot of
questions about testing and she wanted
to provide information in response to
that about uh about how to apply a test
should people decide to use a test they
have also conveyed in their guidance and
they can speak for themselves of course
that uh that uh transmission and
infectiousness occurs in the first five
days after diagnosis with coven 19
somewhere in the range of 85 to 90 90 of
the time hence their guidance on the
five days so they can speak to their own
guidance it is led by data and science
it is not determined here by the white
house as determined by the data and the
scientists who work at the cdc
you see um you know rochelle willinski
and dr kochi as we've talked about
earlier this week had conflicting
accounts of whether testing was
necessary dr wolinski said part of that
consideration was what people would
tolerate and we know that it's important
to keep schools open to keep the economy
running isn't it time to
incorporate some of those other uh
messaging points into
this administration's discussions about
you know how we emerge from this
pandemic we talk about how it's led by
the science and we're following the
science but it seems like we're also
following you know economic needs and
political needs and logistically well
here's the difference from the last
administration uh we are not uh driving
our decision making on how we're
addressing the pandemic through
messaging uh or through political
concerns we're driving it by what the
cdc and the medical doctors and the
experts there convey
they change their they update their
guidance they change their guidance
certainly i'm sure they have
disagreements internally about what
guidance they should put out
that is a healthy part of a discussion
of a policy process but that's what
we're driven by and that's also why we
do covet briefings so that you all can
ask those questions as you just did this
morning an hour ago
the president yesterday said this
continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
isn't it also fair to say that it's
still also a pandemic of the vaccinated
given the breakthrough cases that we've
been seeing well jackie we also know
that you are seven times 17 times uh
more likely to die of covid if you are
not vaccinated and 20 times more likely
to be hospitalized
so i think in terms of the impact the
dire impact on people across the country
we should be very clear about
the impact of not getting vaccinated and
the people who will be uh be hurt uh be
hospitalized and
face the threat of death the most and
those are the people who are
unvaccinated last question on the cdc
announcement um or rather the covert
briefing announcement the cdc is not
going to change its definition
of fully vaccinated to include a booster
shot jeff science and
richelle lindsey said there's no plans
for that
they didn't explain though why that is
can you give us some context and how
that decision was made again i would say
that's a decision made by our health and
medical experts um you know they
conveyed the technical definition as you
said a fully vaccinated with coven 19
has not changed someone is considered
fully vaccinated if they receive a
primary series of vaccines they also
clarified that cdc recommends people
stay up to date as as everybody should
stay up to date on any vaccine if your
kid needs a vaccine when you go to the
pediatrician and they say you get a five
year you know a vaccine at five years
old you kind of hold your breath because
you don't want to have your kid get a
shot but you keep it up to date uh and
that's what they're recommending but
they can speak to their own decision
making go ahead trevor uh jen so next
week i know we've got these three tracks
of talks with um russia yeah one is u.s
russia one it's nato russia another's
broader european security dogs for the
for the u.s russia talks are there is
there scope uh you know in terms of what
the agenda looks like what are the
specific areas you want to focus on sure
that's exactly right there are three
sets of talks and next week they start
on the 10th in geneva those will be led
by deputy secretary sherman then there's
the 12th in brussels the nato-russia
council and then the 13th in vienna
which is the osce which will start then
will be represented by our ambassador to
the osce mike carpenter so let me give
you a previews you just asked for what
to expect um russia's has eight has of
course raised as you've seen them raise
uh publicly they've also raised
privately the issue of european security
let's be clear over the past two decades
it is russia that has invaded two
neighboring countries interfered in many
other elections used uh country used
chemical weapons to attempt
assassinations on foreign soil and
violated international arms control
agreements we and our allies will be
raising those issues uh and other issues
with russia in the days and weeks ahead
and certainly as a part of these talks
and of course we cannot forget that
there is an ongoing russian military
occupation in ukraine in addition to the
three meetings next week we will
continue to actively support progress on
the minsk accords to resolve the current
conflict in the don boss there have been
a number of proposals of course that
russia has already published or put out
there advocated for uh president biden
has made clear
that we can make progress on some issues
while others are not viable we're not
responding to them point by point and i
don't expect we will in these
negotiations because in our experience
you don't make actual progress by
negotiating in public and also because
many of the proposals don't merit such a
response but russia is very familiar
with our positions which are grounded in
the fundamental principles of european
security they once agreed to including
that borders could not be redrawn by
force and countries have the sovereign
right to determine with whom they
associate finally we don't know what
next week's conversations will bring
but our approach to discussions will be
pragmatic results oriented and we
believe there are areas we can make
progress on with moscow
make progress on uh if if they come to
the table ready to do that um and
obviously that's the nature of diplomacy
well that's right just one more within
that region we've also had seen
a lot of instability in kazakhstan
is
is that something that the white house
has a position on yeah we have obviously
um as you noted we have seen that and we
have we're monitoring reports of
protests in kazakhstan we support calls
for calm for protesters to express
themselves peacefully and for
authorities to exercise restraint
there are some crazy
russian claims
about the u.s being behind this so let
me just use this opportunity to convey
that as absolutely false and clearly a
part of the standard russian
disinformation playbook we've seen a lot
of in past years go ahead
on this plan or agreement that the white
house had with walmart and kroger to
sell those rapid tests it cost did the
white house make an effort to extend
that agreement
well i'm not going to get into details
of our private conversations with these
providers it was a set number of a set
period of time but what's important to
um for people to understand or the
american people to understand is that
our focus is of course ensuring that we
are increasing access
and access to free tests to people
across the country so obviously that has
been the case selling them at cost
something that we strongly supported
advocated for for the last uh couple of
months uh since that time the president
has quadrupled the size of our testing
capacity we have announced the intention
to
purchase 500 million we're in the
process of finalizing those contracts of
course tests we've made 20 000 testing
sites available we've opened a range of
federal testing sites across the country
so our objective is to continue to
expand access to free tests uh for the
american people across the country and
i'd also note of course next week people
can submit uh to their insurers and
we'll have more details on that i know
you asked about that yesterday on how
that will work um can submit to their
employers or i mean sorry to their
insurance companies to get reimbursed
for their tests as well but i guess the
point is this half a billion tests
aren't available yet you can't go on a
website and sign up for them yet you
can't receive them yet
you can't yet file a claim with your
insurance company to be reimbursed for
the test that people have been buying
and so i'm wondering
since the president has had the ceo of
walmart here at the white house before
they have a pretty close relationship
since he took office why he would not
try to extend that agreement that they
had with walmart that the white house
out of walmart to keep those tests a
little bit less expensive than they
already are well i'm not going to detail
private conversations but i will just
reiterate that next week people can get
reimbursed for their uh for their tests
i just announced at the top of this
briefing a number of additional federal
testing large sites that we're opening
we have 20 000 free testing sites across
the country and we are very close to
being able to announce the put put up
the website so people can order uh if
they desire free tests to be delivered
to their home so we are very close to ex
continuing to expand
access to free tests and that's what our
focus is on and of course we certainly
believe and our focus continues to be
that we don't want any american to be in
a positions where tests are only
available at an untenable price that's
why we are expanding free testing why
make the decision to have people have to
file a claim with their insurance
companies for each rapid test that they
buy to be reimbursed by the companies
instead of just making the rapid tests
free we are making the test free this is
an additional step
we're making them 500 million of them
free to people who want tests and we'll
continue to build on that but this is
another step people can take 150 million
americans who are insured to
get reimbursed by their insurance
companies and expect we'll have more on
that uh in short order a few other
questions i have uh tomorrow the
president is going to speak uh on
capitol hill is he going to address his
predecessor's role in the riot
uh yes let me give you a little more
preview of that um
so um in addition i know i noted this
yesterday but i think it's important for
people to let me briefly reiterate um
the president's going to speak to the
truth of what happened not the lies that
some have spread since and the peril
opposed to the rule of law and our
system of democratic governance he will
also speak to the work we still need to
do to secure and strengthen our
democracy and our institutions to reject
the hatred and lies we saw on january 6
and to unite our country
i'd also note that president biden has
been uh clear-eyed about the threat the
former president represents to our
democracy and how how the former
president constantly works to undermine
basic american values and rule of law
and president biden has of course spoken
repeatedly about how the former
president abused his office undermined
the constitution and ignored his oath to
the american people in an effort to
amass more power for himself and his
allies
he sees january 6 as the tragic
culmination of what those four years
under president trump did to our country
and they reflected the importance
to the president of winning uh what he
has called many times and you've heard
him call many times the soul the battle
for the soul of our nation so just as
you heard him say on january 6 of last
year i would expect that president biden
will lay out the significance of what
happened at the capitol and the singular
responsibility president trump has for
the chaos and carnage that we saw and he
will forcibly push back on the lie
spread by the former president in an
attempt to mislead the american people
and his own supporters as well as
distract from his role and what happened
so uh he will of course speak to the
moment uh to the importance in history
of the peaceful transfer of power of
what we need to do to protect our own
democracy and be forward-looking but he
will also reflect on the role his
predecessor had will he call donald
trump
uh we'll see we're finalizing the speech
but i think people will know who he's
referring to one more question when it
comes to voting rights and you've talked
about how important that is to the
president will he directly call senator
joe manchin and senator kirsten sinema
about voting rights he is in touch with
a range of members of the senate uh
including those you've mentioned about a
range of topics that are of a priority
to him including voting rights but we're
not going to outline more details from
here have you been in touch with them
this week i'm just not going to outline
more details of private conversations
from here go ahead kristen thank you
before i get to what's happening in
washington i'm wondering if the
president has been briefed on the tragic
fire in philadelphia we know that 13
people so far have been killed in that
fire i i have seen those reports
absolutely devastating a number of
children but i will have to get an
update on if he's been briefed i know
they were just coming out as we were
coming out here okay thank you um going
back to the cdc and the new guidelines
they have come under criticism with a
lot of
parents teachers
other folks saying they're just flatly
confusing and that there was a
clarification put out yesterday that
doesn't feel much like the clarification
and i guess the question is
does president biden
have confidence and is he satisfied with
the job that the cdc is doing
he has confidence in the uh the
scientific expertise uh the medical
expertise of the team at the cdc
and he believes the american people
had a desire a need
for us to address this pandemic led by
data and science and that's what he's
going to continue to rely on one of the
things that people are focusing on is
this idea that people can decide whether
to get a test or just ask a version of
this but i guess the question is
why should it be up to individuals to
assess their own symptoms or whether
they even have symptoms
again i think kristin i would encourage
you to ask the cdc director and
the cdc any specific questions about
their guidance they're determined and
issued by them
senator schumer majority leader schumer
said yesterday that he expects
negotiations to resume
shortly in the near term between
the president and joe manchin about
buildback better do you have and you
were asked about this yesterday but let
me see if i can get an update okay
um any timeline or guidance on when
those discussions might start and will
they just start in short order or is
voting rights the priority right now
well we can walk and chew gum at the
same time and i can assure you that we
are in touch with a range of senators
and their staffs and committee staff
about buildback better even as we're
working uh in lockstep with leader
schumer about getting voting rights done
a huge priority to the president so i
would not confuse the legislative
calendar uh with a lack of action or
behind-the-scenes discussions about an
important priority
ultimately for the larger goal of seeing
buildback better pass be willing to sign
a final
piece of legislation that did not
include an expanded child tax plan i'm
just not going to negotiate from here
but the president obviously sees the
child tax credit extension as a key
priority
he sees it as a benefit that has
provided
essential assistance to families across
the country has uh cut
childhood poverty by 40 percent and
that's an amazing statistic i'd also
know i mentioned this yesterday but i
got a little bit more
information on it so um
we are going to continue to fight
absolutely to
have it done i would note though that
americans who qualified for the extended
child tax credit will still receive half
of the entire benefit when they file
their taxes this year so the families
who have received monthly payments will
get up to eighteen hundred dollars for
each child under six as when they file
their taxes and up to fifteen hundred
dollars for each child age six to
seventeen obviously that doesn't address
what happens after here but just an
important component for people to know
and understand and just finally quickly
on the speech tomorrow you've given us a
little bit of a preview of the substance
can you talk about how the president is
spending this day in terms of preparing
to deliver this speech how much is he
focused on that today is he doing dry
run-throughs i mean obviously this is a
significant moment sure look i would say
first um yeah i know the president
doesn't have public events today he does
have a number of uh meetings with uh
policy teams and that's often what he's
doing behind the scenes if you if he
were standing here today which i know
he's always invited he's what you guys
will say but he would say we never give
him any free time or any time to think
um and that is probably true so that is
a big part of his day-to-day uh he is
obviously very personally involved in
what he's going to say tomorrow and as
somebody who served 36 years in the
senate uh you know he watched in horror
as many people who were in congress that
day whether they were members or staff
or people who just had been working in
the capitol building for some time at
what a dark day that was in our
democracy it hit him personally
and i think the role of the former
president in this the role and
unfortunately the silence and the
complacency of a number of far too many
not every but far too many member of the
republican party uh in the time since
then in perpetuating the big lie has
stuck with him as well so i will say i
would say that of course he he's
involved in the writing of any major
speech he gives uh in feedback um and
and conveying
whether it's meeting the moment of what
he wants to say uh but certainly
tomorrow the significance of it is
something that uh he feels personally
about
good um on the idea of some fresh uh
spending on
coping relief for small businesses
first of all can you share some reaction
to that and then also with the white
house be open to spending for
restaurants hoped to really prevent
restaurants or would would the president
be opposed to that
well uh we as you know we did a major
relief package that included helping
restaurants just last year we are in
constant discussions with congress and
leadership about the needs of the
american people whether they are small
businesses or restaurants or people
sitting in their homes as we continue to
fight the pandemic but don't have any uh
new prediction of pending or new pending
requests or specific requests and
wouldn't predict that at this moment in
time
on the federal reserve
on the search does the white house have
a clear idea from senator manchin how he
would vote on some of these nominations
has the president been running some of
the names by him to see how he feels i'm
just not going to have an update on that
for you okay and then a question on some
big tech legislation um do you know if
the president supports the house package
of antitrust bills to rein in big tech
i know that they were brought up in june
yeah has he asked the speaker to bring
any of those bills to the floor
so here's where we are um i mean the
president's view is that um the history
of the country suggests that strong
anti-trust laws have been a key to
american technological leadership and
preeminence and for generations american
our approach has been to expose our main
tech firms to more competition the
president has been very clear in his
view that we need more competition in
the tech industry that's his fundamental
view you saw that in
the executive order on competition he
signed in july uh and uh his view is
that uh over the past 10 years the
largest tech platforms have as they've
acquired hundreds of companies including
alleged killer acquisitions meant to
shut down a potential comp competitive
threat that's not a healthy place for
the system and the large platforms um
the large platform's power gives them
unfair opportunities to get a leg up on
small businesses that will uh that rely
on them to reach customers um the
president also called on federal
agencies like doj and the ftc to use
their existing tools to tackle these
problems uh in the executive order i
know you're specifically asking about
the legislation we're continuing we're
encouraged he's encouraged uh to see
bipartisan interest in congress and
passing legislation to address the power
of tech platforms through anti-trust
legislation and to protect privacy i
don't think we've done a statement yet
of administrative policy on this
particular legislation but we're in in
discussion we're encouraged by um the
bipartisan interest in doing something
about this
go ahead uh question on climate uh truth
senator manchester's comments yesterday
about reaching a deal on climate uh what
is what else's reaction to that and
there's a possibility that that could be
uh sectioned off and reached a separate
deal on that
uh i'm not going to have any direct uh
reaction to to senator manchin's
comments um which were extensive and he
frequently talks to the press which of
course is a good thing um but i would
say that uh a key component of the
president's buildback better agenda is
climate um and addressing the climate
crisis that's how he feels um it's it's
vitally important to him as you know
there's a significant uh
investment in addressing the climate
crisis in the bill and legislation that
we have been uh working uh on with uh
congress on um and that's important
because well we have taken a number of
steps
from the administration with the power
he has as president tackling super
pollutants phasing down hfcs rallying
the world on methane in glasgow
standing with auto workers and america's
big net car manufacturers to roll up
plans to boost electric vehicles putting
america on track for one of every two
cars sold to be zero emissions these are
important steps he's taken on his own we
know that working with congress on
legislation is is vital and important to
reaching our objectives to reaching our
goals and to really making an impact um
but i'm not going to negotiate from here
on what the specifics are with members
of congress two questions of voting
rights um does the what is a response
senator mcconnell who
was critical of the focus of voting
rights on january 6. this was you know
this day we can use to push democrats
agenda and voting rights and then
secondly uh does the president plan to
address buddhismar and will he address
specifically the filibuster and changing
the rules of the pillar sure i would say
first on this speech tomorrow i can't
believe it's tomorrow um but uh the
speech tomorrow um he will touch on
voting rights um but he will have more
to say on that soon um in a longer
format and the speech tomorrow is more
focused on the day what it means in our
history
and the role that some have played and
continuing to perpetuate uh the big lie
and mis and perceptions in the country
but he will touch on it i would note as
it relates to specifically the
filibuster um in march just to go back a
little bit here because i expect we'll
be talking about this more um the
president said he had quote an open mind
about dealing with certain things that
are just elemental to the functioning of
our democracy like the right to vote
like the basic right to vote we've
amended the filibuster in the past he's
also said previously that senseless
obstruction would be a big factor for
him and i think there's no question
objectively republicans have not once
but four times obstructed basic
legislation that should not be partisan
but is about upholding our constitution
as they simultaneously attack the most
fundamental american right the right to
vote uh he also said back in december
that if necessary he supports a rule
change to uphold the sacred right of
americans to vote uh and this is
reflective of the fact that well he is a
creature of the senate and somebody who
respects the uh history of the senate he
wants the senate to function
and he wants to move towards and is open
to rules changes that will help the
senate function uh so i expect he'll
have more to say about that but i just
wanted to note a couple of the things he
said including right before christmas
sorry you said a longer format down the
line is there another speech planned
ongoing rapes we'll have more to say
soon but he'll have more to say tomorrow
uh past tomorrow in another format about
voting rights
i wanted to kind of piggyback on what my
colleague was just saying because i was
wondering does he plan to visit the
senator law and do a full viral speech
on reform um just as he did when he went
to the house regarding uh the
infrastructure bill can we see that and
back on the speech again i know you
can't give out everything however um in
calling out trump is he also going to
speak directly to his own party that
have stood in the way of the filibuster
well again i would just note that
tomorrow while he will touch on voting
rights is not a voting a speech about
voting rights and he will have more to
say about that soon in terms of the
location and the format i don't have
anything to preview for you at this
point in time but i think you can expect
he will make a passionate case for
voting rights as he has done on a number
of occasions in the past and he will do
that soon
i want to ask a quick question um on
coven talking about the tests that are
going to be available free online what
is the administration doing to um
confront communities underserved
communities that don't have broadband
access that are going to have trouble
getting and ordering these tests online
what is the administration doing on that
end
well i would say it's not it is an
important tool but it is not the only
way that we are providing access to free
testing across the country and certainly
ensuring that we are
reaching communities that may have
challenges because of lack of broadband
access or the inability to order online
as part of our objective i i started
this briefing announcing a number of the
um federal testing sites that we've
opened and ones that we will continue to
expand this is in addition to the 20 20
000 tests we have available across the
country a 50 million tests are in the
process of going out started in december
to rural health centers and community
cell health centers though a lot of
those are targeted to lower income
communities communities that may not
have access to broadband or be able to
order on their computers and we will con
mobile testing sites is something that
we off also continue to build out so we
will continue to build out all of those
options because obviously equity is a
key priority to the president as we work
to address covet go ahead daniel um i
have two questions french president
emmanuel macron said this week that he
plans to hassle the unvaccinated to try
to get them to get the shot since there
are millions of americans who have not
been persuaded by
uh you know the various government
campaigns to get vaccinated does uh you
know why hasn't the president focused
more on kind of scolding the
unvaccinated to try to tell them hey
this is not working for society
you know we keep getting these shutdowns
well i would say that um
if you look just to a little over a year
ago last december only about a third of
the american people were willing to get
a shot and today over 85 percent of
american adults have at least one shot
uh and more than 70 percent are fully
vaccinated so our our objective has been
to uh continue to convey to the american
people uh the fact that getting
vaccinated will help protect them from
hospitalization from death that will
help protect their loved ones
it will help protect their neighbors and
their community
and we've had a great deal of success in
that uh and obviously the french will
make their own decisions about the most
effective way to communicate with their
public they're going to be any change in
strategy in terms of messaging
you know you guys have had like the
jonas brothers and others but like what
do we you know joe
more jonas brothers um you know i would
say daniel that that our approach to
date has been that we have looked for
trusted messengers and some of them uh
may have been people who supported
president biden and many of them were
not um and it's been important to us to
reach communities meet people where they
are uh including with voices some of
them have been local officials we found
and this is no surprise to most people
who've been covering politics but local
officials local leaders pediatricians
they are often the most trusted voices
in communities but also uh to work with
voices of people who again may not have
voted for the president uh but can be
effective in helping uh encourage people
to get vaccinated yesterday uh senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell said
that democrats version of the big lie
is their concern that republicans are
making it uh harder for people to vote
does the white house have a response to
what mcconnell said
well i would just say facts are facts
and when you make it harder to vote you
make it harder to vote so let's just
give a couple of examples um
michigan republicans have been replacing
members of county boards of canvassers
who voted to certify the 2020 election
results and are replacing them in some
cases with individuals who ascribe to
the big lie georgia passed a law that
allows the state legislator to control
the state election board and in turn
allows the state elections board to
remove local election officials who
manage the voting and counting process
texas passed a law that makes it easier
for partisan poll watchers to hover
around people while they vote and
intimidate them montana passed a law
that repeals same-day voter registration
makes it harder for people to vote by
mail and republicans in arizona
pennsylvania and wisconsin have been
pursuing purported audits of the 2020
election something that's been thrown
out of 80 courts in service of the big
lie so if that is not making it more
difficult to vote i don't know what is
uh but maybe uh mr mcconnell has a
different definition of that go ahead
thanks jen i have the january 6th
anniversary tomorrow does the president
think attorney general mayor garland has
done enough
to investigate the attempt to overturn
the 2020 election and also some
republicans are accusing democrats to
playing politics with the anniversary
does the president think like
bipartisanship and relations between the
two parties are better or worse off than
they were a year ago um well on the
first one we do something different here
we leave any decisions about
investigations to the independent
justice department something that the
attorney general uh naturally demanded
and the president uh wanted to in his in
his justice department and his attorney
general
and in the second i would say that uh
what you'll hear the president talk
about tomorrow is the fact that uh you
don't just love your country when you
win
uh you love your country you love
democracy uh in any in any scenario and
uh what is most disappointing uh to him
is that there has been a silence and at
times a complacency by far too many
republicans who have sat by and defended
the big lie
and perpetuated misinformation to the
american public
that is not meant to be a partisan that
is meant to be a statement of fact uh
and an important reminder to people
about the history of our democracy in
this country and i think that's what
people will hear from him tomorrow i
just have to get quickly around here
because i want to get to everybody go
ahead i have a question on testing you
started by talking about testing
capacity and increasing testing capacity
i'd like to know if the administration
federal government is doing anything to
increase testing processing we've seen
the lines of people waiting but they're
also waiting a long time to get those
results and that keeps society from
moving forward so what is the
administration doing to help with that
processing gap i know that question was
just asked on the coveted briefing it's
a very good question i believe they said
they'd look into more information so let
me see if they have more on that one
more question for you
similar vein with the omicron variant
having such a big impact perhaps an
outsized impact than we were expecting
is the administration
eyeing any additional proven relief i
know jen asked about restaurant leaf but
just sort of a larger package to help
people sort of get through this new
phase of profit
the same answer applies we are
constantly in conversation with congress
and leadership and members about what we
think and what they think the american
people need in any moment but it's
important also to remember we are in a
very different place than we were
a year ago or six months ago
historic records of job creation
historic economic growth across the
country historic low records of low
numbers of unemployment low levels of
unemployment i should say and 200
million people who are vaccinated so
we're
in constant conversation but in terms of
a prediction of a a specific request um
you know i would say they're constant
conversations but nothing new to report
at this point in time
go ahead uh sorry well let's make uh i
will quickly get around to the last two
or last three go ahead real quick um
asking one question on behalf of a
colleague who couldn't be here from cafe
lucy of the wall street journal does the
white house see the teachers union in
chicago as an instruction to overseeing
schools what is their message to union
leaders
so i believe i answered this a little
bit earlier and the president wants
schools to be open he believes we have
the tools for schools to be open
and we're going to continue to work to
ensure that students are in classrooms
they're in classrooms safely
and and they are for the foreseeable
future and yesterday new york city mayor
eric adams urged local businesses
to return back to their offices we know
that the president has said you know
it's safe to return to schools but um
does he agree with this message that you
know
workers should be going back to their
offices to help out the whole you know
financial ecosystem
local leaders are going to make
decisions about what is safe and best in
their communities um i would say that we
would we would really defer to them um
go in the back uh about the russia the
upcoming russian talks
what are you guys expecting are you
expecting any concrete results after
these three rounds of tops are you just
happy with keeping the line of
communication open with the russians
well i think and hopefully i gave a
pretty extensive preview of what we
expect or what we are going to into the
discussions the three sets of talks to
accomplish uh but i'm not going to make
a prediction of what's going to come out
of them at this point and uh just a
quick follow-up
there's a lot of focus on
if russia does indeed invade ukraine we
will have very harsh consequences for
the for the russian government
what about the status quo what what is
the white house's position on if things
don't change and they don't invade
ukraine
well we are continuing to provide uh
defensive assistance to ukraine uh we've
been providing assistance and we will
continue to do so in the weeks and
months ahead and that is building on of
course when president zielenski was here
and we will continue to uh discuss
working close uh coordination with our
partners and allies in europe uh as we
work uh to reduce and de-escalate the
situation on the border go ahead
thank you jen i have one follow-on
testing and then one separate question
the follow is you say the cdc is driven
by data but i'm wondering what role the
data about just the sheer availability
of tests at this exact moment in time
is playing in the guidance that they're
offering and once those 500 million
tests and all of the various tests that
the white house is procuring once those
come to market could we see the guidance
change well dr wolinski answered this
question on the covet briefing and said
specifically had nothing to do with
access to tests and actually there's a
wide expansive uh we're continuing to
expand the number of tests that are
available but it's not an issue with
tests their guidance a child who has
simply been exposed to covet in school
is going to participate in a test to
stay in school program but someone who
has actually had covid is not required
to test to re-enter society well again i
would point you to the cdc to answer any
specific questions on their guidance
it's driven by their own data and their
own scientists and then on buildback
better cnbc and change research
conducted a poll in late december asking
various demographics about some of the
legislation that's been proposed the
state of the economy pure independence
the group of voters that secured the
election for president biden they give
the president a d across the board on
economic issues and only 30 percent say
that buildback better will grow the
economy and create jobs what is your own
internal polling telling you about
whether independents want buildback
better and whether you should
recalibrate for a different set of
policy proposals well without getting
into internal polling i will tell you
that bill beck better as you know hasn't
passed yet um and we are working to get
it passed and what we see in a lot of
polling is that people like the
components of the pa of the bill but
they don't know exactly what's in
buildback better and what it means um
and it's always easier to sell a package
to the public once it's passed so we're
hoping we're going to get to that point
that is our objective
i would note that
well the economic data is very strong
right now in a lot of areas economic
growth job creation low unemployment
we also understand that the way people
are experiencing
the american public is experiencing a
life right now is through the prism of a
pandemic that is almost we're almost two
years into they're tired of it they're
fatigued by it well it has been an
unpredictable historic pandemic uh they
want it to be over and their experience
with the economy isn't is inherent
inherently tied to that um we understand
that that it's less about data and more
about what people are experiencing in
their day-to-day life it doesn't look
normal they're worried about there being
labor shortages and they're being
canceled flights or not enough teachers
in school because of the spread of
omicron we understand that so our focus
right now is on doing everything we can
to continue to fight the virus we think
that is the biggest driver in making
people feel better about their daily
experiences
and better about
we know the progress that's been made in
the economy thanks so much everybody
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you